aïe aïe aïe mais qu'est ce qu'il va bien
faire comme intro aujourd'hui non il va
pas juste pas aller dans un petit média
ce nul bon si vous avez déjà tous vu des
vidéos très certainement en tout cas sur
le net
dodo rebelles caméra la plupart d'entre
nous connaissent que séméac à me tuer
quand même ce sont des caméras destinées
à filmer devant chez soi en grosse
affirme-t-on palier pour voir ce qui s'y
passe c'est immensément utilisé aux
états unis pour la simple et bonne
raison qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
zones où c'est essentiellement des
pavillons et pas des immeubles et du
coup quand les gens se font livrer un
colis et ben il est déposé devant la
porte
n'y a pas de gardien comme c'est le cas
dans certains immeubles à paris ou même
le livreur peut pas laisser le collier
au troisième étage devant ta porte ce
qui fait qu'il est quand même cachet de
tout cela il est posé en plein milieu
devant la maison tous ceux qui passent
par là le voit et beaucoup d'entre eux
sont attirés par ce qu'il peut contenir
gens rient mais c'est aux rives du coup
voilà il ya plein plein plein de vol de
collier aux états unis ya vraiment des
gars c'est leur métier à plein temps ils
font des tours en voiture ils prennent
donc au lit le mène dans la voiture et
ils font ça dans toute la rue et foncent
à toute la journée puis revendent
ensuite qu'ils ont réussi à choper comme
ça à voler et donc pour contrer sabaya
ces fameuses caméras qui ont été mises
au point et qui filme ton palier et qui
s'active quand il ya du mouvement devant
chez toi et tu peut même parler ya même
un haut parleur et tu pars dans ton
téléphone et ça envoie leçon devant chez
toi ou gars qui est devant ta porte
c'est quand même incroyable
aujourd'hui petite review des meilleures
vidéos selon moi d'en beys caméra moi je
pensais que tout pouvait se passer
devant des maisons c'était juste des
vols de colis mais pas du tout mais
qu'il ya vraiment plein de trucs à
observer grâce à ses caméras
c'est incroyable tout ce qu'on y trouve
première vidéo c'est juste pour montrer
un mec qui est bon là qui vient qui
volent et c'est ouf parce que en voyant
ça je me suis dit ah mais c'est un
livreur ou un gars d'une entreprise qui
déposent des colis pas du tout le mec se
déguise pour faire ça on paraît plus
crédible et que les gens dans la rue se
méfie moins de lui c'est horrible c'est
pas mais collier pourtant j'ai la haine
encore plus ce que c'était les mères
c'est tellement horrible faire ça on
parle de sujets parce que j'ai eu un
déclic en voyant la vidéo cayman s'est
retournée là sur twitter du petit qui
vient sonner en overboard chez son
voisin pour lui faire une blague et qui
part très très vite c'est vraiment le
choc des générations
non me courir utiliser nos jambes
maintenant il n'y a plus besoin d'y en a
du coup en 20 journées qui s'amuse à
regarder
et moment que la caméra a enregistré
donc y compris au moment où quelqu'un
est venu sonner chez toi pour te livrer
un truc commande normale la grecque
s'est aperçu d'un truc horrible c'est
peut-être psychologiquement le même
effet quand tu te fais cambrioler c'est
horrible à meg mais quel genre de
personne faut être pour faire ça moi je
regardais je pense si j'avais ce truc
devant chez moi la caméra je regarderai
jamais les vidéos j'avais trop peur d'y
découvrir des trucs horribles comme ça
un inconnu à but d'anton milkshake et tu
peux rien y faire c'est comme ça c'est
la vie
autant ne pas le savoir des remakes
illustre voir la tête du gars quand il
se rend compte qu il en train de
regarder une caméra web c'est pas un
remplaçant la paille que ça annule ce
que tu viens de faire mon ami pas du
tout et c'est fou c'est que au moment où
la personne ouvre la porte pour
récupérer son budget il a un regard en
mode escale c est ce qu elle sait ce que
je viens de faire son métier
regardez ça se voit clairement sur son
visage ok ça vaut à l'époque où qu'est
ce que c'est qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que c'est d'enfants à faire
voler un colis non il a pris un objet
mais c'est totalement gratuit mais c'est
plus gratuit que l'air ce qui vient de
se passer
salut mec imaginez en partant elle
croise le petit en overboard en fait
toutes les vidéos via du même quartier
c'est un quartier où tous les enfants
sont démoniaques
c'est un enfer abbas assez bas dans mec
à le mec qui veut comme léo léa
il cherche aussi à peine clés cachées
devant la porte quoi surtout
l'indifférence avec laquelle il fait ça
c'est ça qui me terrifie quoi c'est
horrible quoi tu va pénétrer dans
l'espace personnel quelqu'un chez
quelqu'un quoi pour lui voler des choses
et tu pars en mode tranquille quoi comme
si tu venais d'acheter une glace à ça me
terrifie je veux ça me fait vraiment
quelque chose rassurez-vous des fois en
regardant les vidéos de la caméra on
trouve des trucs plus positifs que des
gens qui veulent juste volé je n'ai pas
dit mais la caméra elle est plus ou
moins visible c'est un petit boîtier
comme ça si tu fais un petit peu gaffe
tu la vois quoi et du coup il ya des
gens la voyante qui s'amuse à faire des
trucs gratuits mais gratuitement culpa
gratuit négatifs comme ce livreur que
j'aimerais avoir en tant qu libre et
voilà qu ils regardent auto lui qui est
bien personne pour le juger et dans ce
mec c'est trop cool je trouve ça génial
il sait qu'en arrivant en bougeant il va
activer la caméra et que du coup il y
aura une trace vidéo de ce qui s'est
passé sur ce laps de temps et il prend
le temps de danser pour faire sourire et
envoyer du plaisir aux propriétaires de
cette maison n'est ce pas une âme
charitable franchement et d'ivoire cc
c'est pas facile mais cet homme prend le
temps de faire plaisir j'espère qu'il a
une promotion j'ai voulu dire ups si
vous êtes devant cette vidéo j'espère
vous avez promis cet homme
malheureusement c'est un peu la seule
très positif de ce qui peut se passer
devant chez toi conte est pas là celles
qui vont suivre c'est beaucoup moins
positif avec ce même un peu ghetto mais
mec j'ai besoin que vous m'aidiez à
comprendre
imaginez-vous là après on a vu cette
vidéo vous venez d'installer une caméra
vous vous dites ah là là j'ai hâte de
recevoir une notification à ce qui s'est
passé à la chirurgie a de quoi c'est mon
petit côté curieux j'ai vraiment hâte et
là le lendemain vous êtes au travail
comme ça tranquillement et hop notifs il
se passe quelque chose devant chez vous
il se passe ça
écoutez moi bien là je vous aimais un
petit extrait ça dure trois heures mais
qu'est un gars pendant trois heures
devant chez lui qu'il échet sa sonnette
quel genre de drogue faut-il avoir
consommé pour lécher une sonnette
pendant trois heures mais qu le
traumatisme tu ne peux plus on dit nulle
part après avoir vu sa mecque c'est un
art fair à m
la fonctionnalité qui parle c'est génial
la vidéo vous allez voir c'est une meuf
qui vient pour faire de la pub pour un
truc savez les gens quittant qu'est qui
vous disent de signer ou d'acheter chez
pas quoi sauf que la propriétaire n'est
pas là et du coup la meuf française
elle vient avec ce truc là je sais pas
ce que c'est mais voilà elle c'est un
calendrier peut-être elle me vendre un
calendrier où elle veut que c'est une
pétition elle veut que la barre des
signatures j'en sais rien elle voit la
caméra ok
ok fertois c'est la définition de se
faire remettre à sa place définition pas
il ya un mec aussi qui a fait ça pour
faire partir le chat du voisin qui vient
pisser sur son terrain la surprise ce
n'est pas parce qu'il n'a pas d'êtres
vivants que tu n'es pas surveillé petit
chat c'est un vrai stade dans
l'évolution de l'espèce humaine
on est devenu plus malin que les chats
on peut les surprendre en train de faire
des bêtises
alors qu'avant c'était compliqué ils
savent très bien joué le jeu j'en ai ras
jumbo je sais très bien ici c'est quand
je le vois il sait quand je le vois pas
et quand je vois pas les bêtises ça y va
il ya un truc de ouf c'est que ça a
sauvé la vie d'un mec welch est en
tournage mais dis moi tu vois là là ça
m'aurait bien servi la claque amer je
mets une petite notification j'aurais pu
prévoir et c'est au québec où je vais en
métier faut que je remette une thomas
vidéo a marché sur moi même mec se fout
attends je crois que j'aime vraiment
embêté il attend lyonnais sur le réseau
nova gens mais tu as la fin de la vidéo
journée une vous êtes prévenus à temps
je suis vraiment en train de craquer
pour ce à quoi en pleine vidéo nommée
mecs incroyable alors juste avant son
intervention je vous disais ça aurait
sauvé la vie à quelqu'un donc y'a un mec
ça lui a sauvé la vie il ya un départ
d'incendié devant chez lui et dormait et
la notice de son téléphone la réveiller
et du coup il est il a pu s'en sortir à
temps avant que le feu deviennent genre
vraiment vraiment fort donc sa part
d'une simple poubelle en fait ça ces
temps et n'ont rien regardez là ça
devient littéralement une boule de feu
devant chez lui et donc ça va toucher sa
maison donc pour moi que c'est la nuit
que le mec du coup tu dormais et la
caméra lui envoyer une notification et
ça l'a réveillé et du coup il a pu
s'apercevoir attend qu'il y avait un feu
qu'elle elle atteindra la le réveil
horrible horrible
eyes le mec vient de se réveiller c'est
terrible tu vois ça mais n'importe qui
dit o'shea enfin bref voilà je trouve ça
ouf que ça lui a sauvé la vie parce que
s'il avait perçu la notice a trouv il se
serait réveillée au moment où les
flammes auraient déjà été dans sa maison
quoi donc voilà cette vidéo la mecque
tout est parfait tout est excellent mec
[Musique]
[Rires]
le plus attendu qui sapent ochier sur
lui comme s'il voulait vraiment qu'ils
soient humiliés devant son pote il a pas
chier avant tout quelqu'un longueur et
puissent nettoyer avant de voir son pote
non non non il a chier quand l'ami était
prévenu de son arrivée aux mecs
cette réaction calme me tue de rire il
n'a pas bougé et a juste voulu voir
quelles races d'oiseaux lui acheter bas
les couilles les amis c'est la fin de
cette vidéo en tout cas c'est attendait
principe à la fin il est temps
d'installer notre propre devoir natsu
gambader dans le couloir c'est vraiment
un endroit ça sert à rien de diamètre
c'est là mais j'ai quand même envie de
le faire juste pour que quand quelqu'un
arrive ils soient surpris que je sois au
courant qu'il arrivait à l'est est libre
de plusieurs jours et on installe notre
propre caméra j'en veux tu faire un
caprice
ça y est regardez ce que j'ai reçu je
suis allé au bout de cette impro était
ce une bonne idée
je ne sais pas encore bon écoute je suis
un influenceur influençable c'est à dire
je parle d'un truc en vidéo ça je suis
sur mon cerveau et je l'achète - mc fou
game alors mépris 2,9 j'en ai pris une
douche je me suis fait matrix et
jusqu'au bout elle est allumée salaires
allumées au pied je démarre le test de
connexion ok tout marche nickel je viens
tout après regardez là on voit
actuellement sur mon tel ce qui se passe
dans mon bureau maintenant à chaque fois
que j'y retournerai chez moi je tiendrai
une vidéo je mettrai ça là comme ça
j'anticiperais la venue des gens et on
peut parler en appuyant la halo ça va ou
quoi
c'est génial ça m'amuse courir
incroyable actuellement il ya joker qui
doivent rejoindre au bureau et qu'attend
bah je vais faire monter gelé celle de
surpondérer la caméra on va voir si ça
marche
[Musique]
allô allô jordan allô allô allô allô
jordan et tu l'as tu sors j'ai compris
tu peux la faire tu sonnes là tu sommes
tus à nos questions
tout est raté ça me saoule tour at
stationné là j'ai rien reçu rawson voix
et bien écoutez amis la fin de cette
vidéo est un pur échec mais c'est pas
grave ça n'enlève rien au plaisir qu'ont
appris à regarder les vidéos de ceux
pour qui la technologie à marcher moi ça
n'a pas du tout marché
pourtant on est à un mètre du foutage de
gueule je vous dis à bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo je vais de suite car et
c'est mon chien et john requa
[Musique]